welcome for no to this video el puma a
puma argentino okay never played this
guy via let me do something out they
haven't played this opening for quite a
while at comic-con let's see I is
playing this c4 line I think this is
called the Steiner variation if i'm not
mistaken how is it called now I'm not
sure okay well this this looks like a
position that I should be able to play
without that much theoretical knowledge
I really don't have much theoretical
knowledge mg6 is a bit dicey I think
because of 95 but okay he didn't do it
now White has not played d4 and this
kind of I mean cannot call it a saved
move but it gives white some additional
ideas mostly related to tactics with
Queen a forearm something else trying to
exploit them leading development yeah
here night is a bit I can also go to c7
now I go here ever play Bishop v6 anyway
when the bishop on on only be five is a
piece that will take on c6 or we'll lose
a move at some point it's never really
going to stay there okay so we should be
64 temple right d 5 i'll just take yeah
let's just take take this opportunity in
to win this temple I mean where's the
Queen going actually it doesn't have any
great squares yeah this is one of the
not-so-great squares um John Bishop c4
on 94 it's both pretty good night c 4
for the bishop Pam I'm pretty reliable
to take the bishop and when
have the chance but it's just good right
I mean yeah I think he has to take
otherwise he's running into some forks
and other nastiness he has to take it
good queen bee three I mean blunders the
house Queen a form i just take me to I
don't see why not he seems to still
think about it yeah this is this is what
I was expecting and I wasn't totally
sure about this building because he has
pretty good development and d5 might be
a move but I thought I have bishop defy
of him and that will play it not try not
wasting more time just blocking the pawn
if he takes Queen takes this is kind of
a yeah a dream position against the iqp
and he didn't take yeah well okay it was
as mentioned not not really something I
feared um okay um how to play that he
six looks looks normally I'm fortifying
fortifying g5 9525 white is not in a bad
shape here he isn't he has this good
development and it's not an ideal iqp a
nothing that is brilliant for him but
his active pieces always give him give
him pretty decent play rook c8 is normal
but maybe you can take a take on a seven
ready
9520 596 BC six is certainly an idea fun
maybe I should go night is seven in this
position well that's an interesting move
let's try that Bishop g5 I have f6 yeah
that's not a problem and maybe I can
play Knight f5 it only took me ages to
play the move now that's not good I mean
sorry cannot ninite 1990s doing nothing
on c5 just this is just a bad maneuver
and now I have a fantastic Bishop 1 d 5
which is unchallenged let's see mmm b6
let's push it push it again it has no
with squares any way to go so let's see
Queen d6 maybe I can also just keep
queens on him Queen age 4 moves like
that maybe do that I don't I don't have
much time as usual he played this quite
quickly yeah but I can take here Queen
takes Bishop h6 cannot be any good and
taking where the pawn gives me the total
bishop pair with Bishop to e form huh
we're looking some tactical don't know
when g3 is really am that you don't love
to play I can just go back to d8 if I
want big back to the eighth for Bishop
d7 and then possibly Queen d5 at a later
stage and this is really bad bad pinning
situation okay so this move let's let's
put the rook against the pawn and then
maybe Bishop to AAA they are getting
this back allow us to take on d5 also
with the rook if if you need it okay
let's keep this this is two bishops
against who nights this is Sir in a
somewhat open position is normally good
enough to win the game ready just 95
night h5 is not happening okay g3 is a
really brave move unless it's winning
material which is possible and I'm
overlooking some cities stuff time
morning and jump this this kind of thing
Jim the endgame the endgame is fantastic
but would really like to checkmate the
guy yeah nothing to do and go forth for
the endgame defaults basically gone I
think okay it isn't but still it's two
bishops against two nights the main
problem has mentioned I often lies the
time
check-check
28 seconds it's always amazing what kind
of weird time disadvantages you can can
get into where I mean not you I I can
get into
now I will see one for checkmate ah
Brooksie one was a checkmate I mean it's
just a matter all the time the position
is like over but 20 seconds is not that
much yeah is collapsing on d3 and f2 now
but 60 seconds check yeah now two pieces
I hanging I saw that but the rook
endgame is very good and I can play it
quickly Wow check check
wow I mean sometimes I really wonder
what I'm saying there with the time
checkmate Wow two seconds several just
in time it's just in time I could have
just checked mated the guy I simply
didn't ever expect that he would
overlook the background made and I just
played this so quickly rook c1 is just
made of course I would you know I was
thinking that oh I can always take on d4
and the back rank and so on and then it
just played this and I can go here and
that's it yeah me too kind of made here
Nate yeah it was kind of curious I mean
what really bad was I mean he's still
okay in this position he's got all
pieces in play and it's nothing super
terrible going on but this is really a
bad movie this this gives black a clear
advantage right right basically on a
silver plate yeah now I have the two
bishops until I mean I had them before
but he cannot ever take on d5 yeah he's
just given up on the idea of getting it
getting the bishops of the board and i'm
just-just clearly better here Queen h4s
even better it's a stock fish stock
fishes move b6 route cage yeah I planted
one month later so maybe it wasn't
wasn't so precise what I did he has to
take with the porn I think this then
this position I mean this is simply I'm
really surprised that stock fish is just
on 0.44 me here I mean I was thinking
that this should almost be a win I mean
if you're not screwing it up time wise
or something else I mean this is two
bishops against two nights with nothing
special going on okay push on page 60
here thought g3 is necessary it's ugly
but
yeah this is probably not not best
playing but only I think already was
kind of down on time Queen f3 was also
strong I hate g5 was a move but ok this
is keeps the advantage now this this is
night so we're really personally but you
know I could maybe take on f6 but this
looks ok the Knights look a little bit
like they are stepping on each other's
toes they have no way back when this
this look Teague's here Bishop f3 this
is just this is really winning ok the
check made here I try to attempt him to
do this again but this is winning but
it's of course very tricky to do in 21
seconds but the position is really so
bad with Roxy to coming this is the
domination of two bishops against was
stranded nights ok wow thanks for
watching